hail to the king of the Chiefs Kingdom
forever
because today the team at Lamar
[Applause]
fifty-four
yeah the voice of Mitch halters has been
the voice of Kansas City Chiefs football
for a long time giving voice to what so
many fans of that team and that great
city have been waiting for for so long
and then I includes my good buddy Paul
Rudd back here and the Rich Eisen show
hello Paul
hi rich it's good here it's good here
Mitch say that actually is one of the
first things I listened to and I when I
went on the Kansas City Star the next
day on the website and I listened to his
call now I bet you actually did do that
though right you're not just joking I
really yeah no no I'm not joking
is that your ringtone now ah that's
probably your ringtone - I'd imagine
Mitch Holthus ringtone I need to make my
ringtone idea so now I'll finally get
rid of Hank Stram telling me to
matriculate down here you know it has
been five but it's been five decades of
matriculation that you've now finally if
you will graduate it to the Super Bowl
you know is my ring home before I even
had a cell phone that's so odd but you
know what um it's it's it's just amazing
what what this has been like I'm sure
for you I give you the floor you were
there you were there with your family I
mean what was that day like for you Paul
well I mean it was very you know
thrilling and emotional and I'm
incredible eyes there with my son you
know who has is a die-hard I mean a true
diehard in that way that Nate 15 but
he's been rooting for this team and it's
been a chief fanatic since he discovered
football new product you know six or
seven years old and it's his life and so
you know I got to kind of experience it
as a lifelong fan of the team but then
really as a dad with a kid who you know
when you're a kid and you root for a
team when your team does really really
well I just wanted I just you know to be
able to kind of
experience it a little through his eyes
and we still got a game to go I'm not
you know no but but just wait just but
just but winning that game on on Sunday
was was incredible it was just great
you know I again I know you got a game
to go but still as you know I'm a jet
fan and you just your team just ended a
long drought from Super Bowl four -
mines what one year older Paul and right
you know so I would love to have that
one day and just talk about their still
yeah I know you know you know it's not a
but it's it's you realize like oh yeah
no these there's they're cyclical you
know you don't want the next cycle to be
50 years from now but uh I think about
that too with the World Series when the
Royals won in 85 and then the Mets and
86 and it had been kind of similar
winning a Super World Series for New
York in Kansas City was similar back to
back even though the Mets had been there
I'm getting off topic
no no oils finally won a few years ago
and now this game this could be the
chief's turn it could possibly well you
know one thing that I realized at a
young age because I was a kid when the
Royals won the World Series in 85 was
that the greatest thing that can happen
to a town I think is for that town's
team to win a championship and Kansas
City is a chief town I mean it's crazy
and you know that town supports this
team through thick and thin and the
feeling of excitement and it has been
this way for a while doing no small part
to Patrick Holmes but you know the
entire team and the entire town knows
players that most of the mainstream
media or you know most football fans
might not know yeah they can they can
tell you about Pannell they can tell you
all about Dan Sorenson and they you know
like they love the team we're all
monitoring Chris Jones and his cast you
know where it's it it's a it's a group
effort so it's really exciting to you
know is exciting to be back in Camden
City too and then to go anywhere and
everyone in the town is just decked out
and Chiefs gear Paul Rudd here on the
Rich Eisen show it's gonna be tough for
me and I wonder what it's like for you I
really am beginning to you know wonder
how this game is gonna look and what the
game might be like and and it's tough
for me not to sit here and think this is
mahomes his moment that this is it this
is it you know and I know that Marino
went as a young guy I never went back
but this is just a whole different ball
of wax I'm I don't want to get you too
excited but I I mean it's tough for me
and I have no emotional tie here it's
tough for me to think this is not going
to be his his time Paul well I would
never comment on that you know I do when
I'm in when i'm in football pools and
things like that i never even picked
chief games I just do I devote them I
don't I don't like to I don't do any of
that I get too tied up in the head jinx
anything
I don't even this is the only time I'm
even talking about the cheese because he
was just with you
right right diet you know I'm like this
is not about me this is about cancer
chief no I certainly I certainly hope
you're right I mean I do know that that
kid is pretty special pretty good what a
dream come to know what the forty nights
are pretty good no no I know that and
that's why it's tough for me to sit here
to say that I mean they are ferocious up
front I mean they do have the ability
you know Bosa in particular to try and
you know if anybody that can track
mahomes down when he's trying to gain
the edge like he did against tennessee
which must have lit up Arrowhead that
that that they can do that you know they
can ya know they can I hope they don't
but they certainly can and you're right
in Arrowhead when that happened
yeah let me mention the pastor Watkins
which was this kind of decade-long
release of just joy and pain and anguish
and angst and everything that that was
huge - but we also have had a history of
losing playoff games in really awful
crazy ways I always felt that this was
the case and nobody talked about it
because it was the Chiefs and unless
you're in Kansas City nobody's really
paying attention so nobody
I don't think took that win for granted
or we're celebrating early you know
there's like a minute and a half to go
and I was not comfortable neither with
my kid people started kind of walking
onto the field and in the clock struck
nazir oh that was the first time we
really cheered I couldn't you know even
when it seemed you know impossible I
still thought maybe it's possible see
what I mean that's in that part of the
reason Paul Rudd here in the restaurant
show why I want to have you on as you
give voice your you are a fan here
you're giving voice to much of Chiefs
Kingdom as the Stonestreet and wriggle
on obviously the rest of your big slick
crew with Koechner in a couple more
minutes left with you sir I I did notice
when you were banging the drum to start
that appeared to me to be quite the
cardio workout it looked like you were
pounded in about 30 times there was an
individual there kind of like in giving
you orchestration and when to bang it
and it looked like you were slowing down
at the end I wonder if you can walk me
through this process Paul Rudd it's a
strange feeling to be a high above
Arrowhead Stadium and look out at the
crowd and know that you know you're
leading them and by the way I believe my
official title might have been cheer
captain
okay very good
sound as cool but but it was it was an
exciting straight
cool thing to be a part of something
that is historic that I've
so many other people you know do that I
believe it was a tomba Holly even before
me like a couple weeks ago and yeah if
it's the coolest thing Tony Gonzalez I
seen do it yeah it's it's great yeah we
just added by the way at the bottom of
your the screen Paul Rudd Chiefs cheer
captain just will take a screen grab
I'll send it to you later thank you I'll
send that to you how do you not I can
get pretty little alright last thing for
you because you uh you you did this for
us
two years ago we want our championship
and fantasy football last year we just
we just stuck with our art we changed
our team name from touch of the Vermeil
to man spread centerpiece and it's the
only thing Andy Reid didn't win this
year even though he was our avatar with
his man spread at the NFL owners meeting
for the for the coaches photo I have
here six fantasy football names that we
have just out organically mentioned
these names on the air in conversation
that we're gonna place in context for
you I've got six names I wonder if you
can tell me what our clubhouse leader
going into the offseason should be for
next fall Paul can you do that for me
yes indeed you ready you ready here all
of them Chris Brockman's got the names
over there I'm gonna place them in
context for you here okay the first one
was in relation to Tom Brady perhaps we
can figure out what his yeah thank you
for the for the film's music we could
figure out where he might be going and
what his future plans might be based on
the fact that he moved houses so Chris
Brockman give Paul Rudd the name Zillow
of smoke Zillow of smoke okay keep that
in your mind okay this one I think was
basically from the fact that round ball
rock that music from the NBA on NBC from
all those years ago that John Tesh
created you've got this one Chris Tesh
mood setter cash mood setter
- mood okay next one is based on the
fact that when Jerry Jones according to
DeMarcus Ware tries
get you to sign a contract he brings you
into his office turns down the lights
and lights a candle go for Chris
Brockman Jerry Jones votive candle Jerry
Jones votive candle is your third one
okay Paul you ready for the next one I
went I went crazy on Twitter I know
you're not on Twitter but I went crazy
on Twitter and mahomes did come up with
a 27 yard score against Tennessee at the
Hat but for the end of the half and I
said it was one of the greatest runs in
the history of the NFL many people came
back at me including my brother-in-law
Scott who texted me if what was better
Normandy or mahomes that's the team name
Normandy armored Normandy or mahomes
what do you think of that one I do like
that one okay bar I mean so far and this
is you know not being a cheese and I
think I like that one the best
okay here's two more that's Trek alright
so so here's the last two bill Waltons
spread peanut butter on a television
camera the other day and then licked it
off the lens giving me give him a name
right here slow mo Walton tongue slow mo
Walton tongue and then the last one
based on when there was too many holding
penalties in the Thursday night football
game give it right there
Shawn Hockley flag Perez Shawn Hockley
flag parade slow Moulton Walton tongue
Normandy or mahomes Jerry Jones votive
candle test mood setter or Zillow of
smoke Paul Rudd what do you think
well what last time I think I picked you
your your team name just opting over
deep cut Loggins if I remember I can do
that that's a great memory Paul yes yes
and and didn't you win with touch of
Vermeil yes we did all yes we did we
took it home wanna win again
go with another another teeth can
actually go with Norman dear my
there it is Paul okay what's our avatar
eye or do you go slo-mo Walton tongue
just because it's cryptic it is written
it is cryptic and again you're the man
who once had a fantasy name called Dench
exclamation point right for Jenny that's
right but which one which was your team
name this year
Oh God I did think it was a amend
breakfast breakfast oh my gosh yeah I
think it's meant breakfast a men's
breakfast this year
Oh God I've had a couple I had a couple
of teams okay that's good I had one team
that I didn't really care that much
about and I actually named the team I
have a structured settlement and I need
cash now call you the man hope to see
you down in Miami along are you bringing
your son to the whole Rudd foothold
you run in the back you might son and
yeah yeah we're gonna be there they're
running it back Paul can't wait to see
you looked over to see your mom you too
rich that's Paul Rudd it's Paul Rudd
your good luck to your Chiefs and we'll
see Paul Rudd down in Miami don't go
anywhere we are back with more right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app